Lindsay Lohan is making her return to  the small screen with a new look  the actress debuted this chic hairdo on  set of her new show sick note I'm ready  on Monday the Mean Girls star took to  Instagram to announce she is joining the  cast of the British comedy series for  season 2 the 30 year old actress posed  alongside her co-stars Rupert Grint and  Nick Frost on set she showed off her  signature fiery red hair styled in this  blunt cut Bob for her acting comeback  the former child star last appeared on  TV in 2014 on an episode of two Broke  Girls I'm thinking according to The  Hollywood Reporter Lindsay will play the  daughter of grits boss on the show  played by Don Johnson while season 1  premieres in the UK this fall Lindsay  will reportedly not make her big debut  until next year we're gonna have to wait  for that  [Music]